hello everyone i guess i have the
pleasure of introducing jared
um he is the person that taught me
everything that i know or at least the
foundations of
starting everything i know and so i've
been
very lucky to take my first data science
class through with him
and without further ado uh here's jared
the
one of the own organizers of this event
so i'm going to be talking about
accelerating our code
dramatically speeding it up from
something that takes forever to run
hours if at all
into seconds this is going to be
somewhat similar to a talk i gave at the
first
r conference six years ago that was more
of a survey
this will be more of a problem i had and
walking all the way through it and all
the different paths i took
so what was the ask what were we trying
to
solve what are we trying to accomplish
here
out of millions of points which are
similar to each other
essentially which points are within a
certain distance of each other
it's a range searching problem so
what's the problem about this what's the
big deal
it's slow and the question becomes
how slow is it i want to quantify how
bad this is in terms of calculations
so this problem takes n times n minus 1
divided by two calculations
that's a quadratic relationship for half
a million rows that's 125 billion
calculations
that's a 125 billion slots in memory
for a million rows that's 500 billion
calculations
i doubled the rows but i quadruple the
calculations
the calculations are big o of n squared
and a million rows really isn't that
much data
so let's check out the data for this
particular problem
this is just a sampling of about 500 000
points and it's simulated data
the actual data set had millions and
millions of rows
now each row only has two dimensions
which is nice it's not a high
dimensional problem it's two dimensions
and remember we want to calculate how
similar each row is
to every other row and then we want to
find the ones that are closest to each
other
according to some definition
visualizing the data it looks like a
rorschach test
and we can see that there's more density
in certain parts of the plot than in
other areas
for my first attempt i started with the
obvious function
dist it's built into base r and it
returns the distance between
every pair of rows so i call this
function
and it did not go well i don't know when
it's going to finish
crashed many sessions so
that didn't work had to go back to the
data and look at it again
and i noticed something when i looked at
the ranges of the x and y
axis i said something's up and i
summarize them
the first dimension goes from negative
100 to 100
the second dimension goes from roughly 5
to 68.
and i said you know what that looks a
lot like latitude and longitude data
and if it looks like that maybe i can
use the tools in the sf package
to treat this stuff like their
geometries
so i use st as
sf to convert the data into
geometries and i treat var 1 and var2 as
latitude and longitude
it's now like points on a map they
weren't points on the map
there's no reason we couldn't use that
technology to work with it
so i decided let's plot it on a map and
it looks like this blob trying to take
over the earth
again the map isn't really that useful
because
you know the data aren't meant to be
mapped but i want to see what it looks
like
so now that we're using sf we can use a
function from sf called
st distance now this is from sf
but it requires that the lw geom package
be loaded and this measures the distance
between every point and every other
point
and i figure it's in the sf package it's
meant for geometry it's going to be
great
it was a bit of a dumpster fire or
rather a computer fire
it didn't finish so i turned my
attention to another function in sf
st is within distance it's exactly what
we want
you'd give it geometry points and it
tells you which points are within a
certain distance of each
other now this function is meant to be
used with meters i know there's a new
way to do it with latitude and longitude
data but it's very new
so i convert it into meters i'm taking
my data which i pretended to be lat long
i'm not converting that to be meters i'm
like two steps removed from the original
data
and i had to convert my real threshold
into meters which i had was roughly
eleven thousand which was
not exactly a one-to-one crossover but
is worth a shot
so i run this and once again
it didn't finish i needed a new idea
so i go back to the data which is still
being plotted on a globe
and i could see physically that there
are some points which are just
dramatically farther away from other
points
like the far left is nowhere near the
far right so why am i comparing a point
on the far left to the far right or the
far top to the far bottom
so i thought let's split up the data
into a grid
let's break it up and analyze different
sections of the grid
separately so continuing to use sf
there is a function st make grid this
takes the range of the data
and evenly fills it with equal sized
boxes
these boxes can be squares or in our
case hexagons because they fit in better
our goal is to get the grid cells small
enough so we're not comparing too many
points at once
but not so small that st make grid has a
tough time doing the computations to
make the grid
so we visualize this now and we can see
that the points fall into individual
hexagons
so now instead of comparing all the
points i'm just going to compare the
points within
a single hexagon assuming the points are
evenly distributed
i now have g the number of groups times
n divided by g
times n divided by g minus one divided
by two calculations
because assuming that there's n over g
calculations in each cell
i just need to look at each individually
and i do this g times
for half a million points and 600 groups
this is about 208 million calculations
that's roughly 125 billion fewer
calculations than before
this assumes that the points are evenly
distributed which they're not and we'll
look into that
the difference is stark between not
grouping and grouping
we're talking millions of calculations
versus billions hundreds of billions of
calculations
but what do we do about the points near
the edges of the hexagons
what if he had two points on either side
of a hexagon border
what do we do about those because they
wouldn't be compared even though they
might be right next to each other
so we inflate the hexagons we use
st buffer to make each hexagon
spill over a little bit into the other
hexagons this way i'm
counting a little bit of the points
outside the hexagon
yes some points near the borders will be
counted twice but we can remove those
later it's not that big a deal
the goal is we now have overlapping
hexagons so no
pairwise distances get missed out on and
you make the buffer really small
just slightly bigger than your threshold
so if you plot it again you can't even
tell the difference
because the buffering is so small you
can barely tell the hexagons are
overlapping
so now we need to find out which points
fall within which hexagon
we do a spatial join using the st join
function
and we say find out exactly which points
intersect st
intersects with which hexagons it's
beautiful that we can do this using sf
makes it really simple
we plot this again now color coding the
points according to the hexagons
remember we're comparing points within a
single hexagon against
all the other points on a hexagon not
having to overlap well the hexagons
overlap but we don't need to compare
outside hexagons it's all done for us
now st make grid and st join
can be slow and i'm trying to bring out
as much speed as possible
so i looked into the hex bin package
which has an eponymous function
and this can figure out which points
fall in which hexagons
and it'll make the hexagons much faster
than st matrid
but it doesn't actually give me the
borders of the polygons
and it can't deal these border issues it
can't create the buffer
and doing that after the fact might
actually take more time it won't be much
faster overall
so this was a bit of a false start i
just went back to the grid we have
so let's examine that grid i want to
count how many
how many points are in each cell so i
drop the geometry because if you count
with the geometry
it has to aggregate the geometry and it
takes a lot longer
i get a count and i remove any hexagons
with only one point in it because
there's nothing to compare it to
so my hexagons now range anywhere from 2
to a hundred thousand points
with the median number of points in
hexagon being 201
that meant the median number of
calculations was 20 000 which is
manageable however the biggest group
still has 5 billion calculations for the
biggest groups that's a lot
but if we add up all these different
calculations
we see we now have to make slightly
under 14 billion calculations
as opposed to 125 billion
that's an order of magnitude faster
so now that the id is labeled we can
split it up
so i first tried group nest which will
take the data frame and rather than
making a group table it will make a list
column of individual tables because i
sometimes find those easier to reason
about
i then use map inside of a mutate to
iterate over that list column and apply
my function to each of them
so i do this i first transform it into
meter so i could use st within distance
i do the group nest to break it up into
a list column and i call st
is within distance on each of them
our problem just went from impossible to
solve to taking hours to run
if each group was small enough for st is
within distance
so we have two issues
group nest can be slow it's actually a
slow process
and st is within distance is slow and
might not even finish
so we'll tackle one thing at a time
we'll first deal with
group nest then we'll deal with st is
within distance
so instead of group nest i use the
combination of group by and group
map group by creates rather than a list
column of typicals it creates a grouped
table and that is a faster operation
then group map iterates over that group
table
and returns a list of results sort of
like dl-ply from flyer
so i swap out group nests and i run this
grouping by cell then i do a group map
applying this
st is within distance over each of the
groups
we now went from hours to minutes
a dramatic speed up just by swapping out
group nest for group map
if each group was small enough for st is
within distance
and we could have made smaller cells but
that would have added computational time
in the cell creation and the joining
so i thought i could still do better and
i turned to data table
because it excels at grouping
so i take my sf object i convert it into
as dot data table
i then pipe that into square brackets
because data table uses square bracket
notation
and you can pipe into square brackets if
you put a dot in front of the square
bracket
i group it by cell as a group by option
in the excel the data table square
brackets then i call the function but
when you normally would do a group by
and data table you're calling individual
columns
but if you want to use a non-standard
function that's not sum or mean or
something like that
you have to call the dot sd object which
is a special
grouped object and that respects the
grouping of the of the data table
and then st is within distance is meant
to be called either on an sf object
or a geometry column so i extract the
geometry column from the dot sd
part of the group's data table our
operation now runs
in fewer minutes and this matters if
you're running this often
if each group was small enough for st
is within distance so at this point
i've realized i needed an alternative
for st is within distance it just wasn't
cutting it
so i turned to rfast
this is a package which has rewritten a
bunch of base r functions to be faster
and it lives up to the name including a
function called dist
with a capital d this works pretty well
and it is fast until you get to 46
342 rows
and i had to dig into why so i looked in
the c
plus code and i saw this function which
computes the number of calculations that
will be needed
it's returning an integer
and that's the problem now remember
integers in r
are 32 bits we saw before
that we need to make n times n minus 1
divided by 2 calculations
in order to figure out this number we
first need to compute n times n minus 1
in memory so at 46 342
this comes out to be 2 billion 147
million 534
622
and this you could be thinking is this
bigger than a 32-bit integer
but 2 to the 32 minus 1 is
bigger than this number so what's the
issue
that's because we use one of the bits
for the sign to tell us if the number is
positive or negative
so we really only have 2 to the 31 minus
1
which is smaller than our number so we
need
a bigger integer and c plus plus
this is where r xlnt comes into play
it's not a 64-bit integer but it's the
biggest integer the machine can handle
which with most modern machines is 64
bits
so i made a change of the code from this
first function returning integers
to the second function returning our
excellent t
i made a pull request but it hasn't been
accepted yet because
they asked me a question and i didn't
notice that until last week
so hopefully this pull request will go
through soon
so then i talked to brian lewis and he
has a package called t-core
that's going to be on cran soon
hopefully it's based on irlba
and it's really designed for computing
threshold correlation matrices
but he told me it can compute it can
identify
points that are within a certain
distance of each other
so i do this for one cell i
convert the sf object into a matrix
using st coordinates
and i pipe it into tdist and tds can
work in parallel
if you register a parallel front end
first and i run this and it returns
the indices of the rows that are close
together and the distance
i then iterated over our data table
to do this to each of the cells
individually a similar code to before
i get the coordinates as x y i drop the
geometry i make it a data table
i then iterate over and pass the matrix
version of the dot
the group.sd object into tdist
now this is great but it relies on the
sparsity of the answer
if there's too many rows that are close
to each other
this slows down so i couldn't count on
this always being fast
so they then thought about torch this is
essentially
a matrix algebra library on a gpu
it's pretty new in r and the r package
is just r and c plus plus
it doesn't rely on python so i was
pretty excited about this
so i turned the geom object into
a matrix using st coordinates and i turn
that into a tensor
and i tell it to be on the gpu by saying
device equals cuda
i then call nnfpdist and this returns
the pairwise distances
this was unbelievably fast for 37
000 rows it finished in 0.003
seconds that's amazing
but my gpu only has 11 gigabytes of
memory
so it's easy to blow through that and
crash once you get past about
60 000 rows and not everyone has a gpu
and it takes time to load the gpu load
the data onto the gpu
for each group and then extract the
results and then clear the gpu memory
again for each group
so there's a lot of overhead so i then
said
i need some custom code so i huddled
together with a few friends michael
bagelmacher casakamoto
and we came up with this algorithm
you first sort the data according to one
dimension one dimension only
the x dimension you then do a double for
loop
you go one row at a time and then do the
inner for loop comparing all the
subsequent rows
you don't look backwards because you've
done that already you just look forwards
you first compute the distance along the
x-axis
x1 minus x2 if that is greater than the
threshold
by the triangle inequality that means
the generalized distance of all the
dimensions has to be
bigger than the threshold also so you
know you failed the threshold
but the bonus is that since your data
are sorted according to this
x-axis you can then break out of the
inner loop and skip all the subsequent
points
because they're sorted all the other
points are going to be farther away and
you get to get rid of all those
computations
for that round of the outer loop so you
save a lot of time
if that passes the test you then compute
the generalized
squared distance you don't compute
distance because that involves a square
root which is costly
you compute the distance the square
distance
and that's on all the dimensions you do
it generalized for all the dimensions
and this could be more than two
dimensions it could be a generalized
distance
now if that distance calculation fails
you
skip it if it passes you then take the
square root and you keep track of the
indices
doing this in r we first allocate an
array for the indices and another one
for the distances
i probably could have made them one
array but this was just quick and easy
i then do a double for loop and if your
eyes aren't burning you can see it's
doing exactly what the algorithm says
you compare the x dimension first and if
that breaks if that's greater than the
threshold you break out the inner loop
if it's not you compare the square
distance if that's good you take the
square root
and make note of the indices and the
distance
running this on a single cell it
finishes 3000 rows in about a second
18 000 rows and 21 seconds and 37 000
rows in 70 seconds
and part of the slowness of that is the
is allocating the array and there is
probably a better way to allocate that
array
but this seems manageable so i'm using
group by
mat and group map to iterate over all
the cells and do them individually
but all those individual timings could
really add up
and slow things down and i can't really
do it in parallel because
that memory inefficiency could really
hurt us because when you do it in
parallel you could really inflate the
memory
i needed to go faster this still wasn't
good enough for me
so i turned to rcpp
which lets you write r like c plus code
this is the same function written in c
plus plus which is more verbose
the first key thing i do is instead of
pre-allocating an array for all the
indices
i make a zero length array
just to keep the indices and the
distances and as i add values i can grow
the year the vectors
and the vector growing a vector in c
plus plus is
much more memory efficient than doing it
in r so we're not going to pay a penalty
for that
i do the double for loop which is much
faster than c plus plus
and i use armadillo to the i use
armadillo to do the matrix calculations
i first check the x dimension i break
out of the inner loop if that doesn't
work
i then compute the generalized square
distance if that works i take the square
root
and i push back my vectors i make an
adjustment because c plus plus starts
counting at zero
and i return the objects as a data frame
i call this on an individual cell for
three thousand rows it finishes in .05
seconds
for 18 000 rows it finishes in half a
second and for 37
000 rows it finishes in 1.3 seconds
this was an insane speed up and i didn't
even do anything in parallel in c plus
plus
so you can see that the c plus code is
going to as you grow your data is going
to be much much much
faster so let's do this for
all the different cells we get the xy
data we drop the geometry we make it a
data table
the data need to be sorted so i use set
key in data table and that sorts the
data and i sort it according to the
first dimension
i then call our function for
each of the groups by using buy
i say dot sd calls so i convert just the
x y into a matrix
and i call my function i get this
beautiful data table back my answers
for the entire data set it took about 30
seconds
and i've tested this on millions of rows
and it still stays about 30 seconds
we went from cannot finish
to finishing in hours maybe
to minutes to seconds
and this really matters when you're
running this algorithm hourly
this really matters getting it down to
seconds timing
and we did this by splitting the data
into smaller pieces using a
smarter algorithm and writing compiled
code
and that made it a solvable problem by
following these three steps
thank you very much